thank you tara
good evening and welcome to this
strategy and resources committee meeting
on thursday
the 6th of january 2020
to my name is councillor richard siddall
and i am the chairman of the committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the setup is meeting is designed
to mitigate for david therefore i'd ask
to everybody to work within the
protocols agreed for member and office
security we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by
president you are giving your permission
to be recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak i will then invite you
at the appropriate time
please reference a page number or
paragraph number when referred to the
agenda papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and ensure that your
american friends remain off when not
speaking
can i draw attention to notice in the
gender papers regarding different levels
and obviously the fire exit is behind me
so moving on to item number two which is
apologies for absence uh tara may i have
the apologies please
um
and um
you tara
to move on to the agenda item three
which is the minutes of the special
meeting hold on november 2022 found on
pages 5-32 are approved as a true and
nike record uh i said move do i have a
second to please
councillor swain
uh if any member wishes to raise a match
of accuracy they need to get indicate
councilman morris chrissy chair just to
say that i am in attendance please thank
you very much council morris christie
that is noted
cancer stamp
yes i have a
a matter of accuracy please uh referring
to the second paragraph of chairman's
notices it says quite clearly
referring to recent changes to the
leadership of the council council
councillor siddall advised he would be
resigning as chairman of strategy and
resources committee commenting on how he
had enjoyed this time as the chairman of
this committee
that is inaccurate i listened to the
tape and actually said he will be
resigning and i think it's really
important because one is a past and one
is a present tense and i think it's only
accurate that the minutes reflect what
you as a chairman said that you would be
doing thank you do i have a second to
please for my
thank you
that's noted thank you very much moving
on um
is that on and it's oh yeah i'm waiting
for green light
and just to say chairman um just so you
think i'm not raising my hand
inappropriately i have listened to the
tape as well if i do listen to the tapes
of committee meetings so yeah thanks i
know that's accurate thank you
last noted thank you very much moving on
uh so any other items of accuracy
okay so we move on to item number four
which is disclosure of interest
and that is disclose the existence and
nature of any disposable proteinary
interests or other punitive interests or
non-product interests
relating to items of business on the
internet having regards to paragraph six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct members are reminded that if any
matters arise during the agenda that
they they may raise a note at that time
uh
councillor durham uh yeah thank you
chairman i have a non-pecuniary interest
as a member of essex county council i
also have a non-pecuniar uh interest in
relation to item seven
uh my late father-in-law has recently
been interred in malden cemetery and i
own a plot uh where my recently deceased
father will go in the fullness of time
thank you thank you councillor
uh thank you chairman i can't find the
the item i had a bit of paper when i
left the house but i can't buy my bit of
paper
i will declare an interest on a certain
item it is to do with actually the
changing places um we're talking about
changing places uh funding for um public
conveniences can i declare an interest
because it does relate to severely
disabled people i just would like to
highlight that not everyone who's
severely disabled
has a visible disability and can be
hidden i will declare an interest
because of a membership of a charity i'm
with that
represents people that suffer from
conditions that i do and it might and it
is related perhaps to that form of um
convenience thank you
answer stan
uh yes thank you chairman the same as
cancer durham i'm an essex county
councillor but there's nothing
non-pecuniary there's nothing on here
that i don't think i can vote for or
participate in thank you very much
uh so you now move on to agenda item
five public participation
uh in accordance with the public
speaking protocol uh the public for no
more than two minutes each may express
views on the matters of business to be
considered
uh the management of this facility uh it
will be within certain timers at my
discretion uh so if i feel that the
speaker would like to speak for longer
then then i may make that decision
and mr raymond of the thames sailing
bars trust has uh raised us questions
according to the new rules approved by
council mr raymond will be accessing the
meeting via teams
uh mr raymond
yes good evening uh chairman um yes
john reagan from the tennessee barge
trust and i'd like to raise a question
relating to my tonight on your agenda
this evening
uh discretionary fees and charges 2022
stroke 23
the thames sailing barge trust is a
volunteer-run charity
owning two heritage sailing barges and
attempts lighter moored on height key we
understand that the council are
proposing to start charging for car
parking on hive key at a rate of 638
pounds per space per annum
for many years we've received four
parking spaces included within our
mooring fees
we appreciate the significant mooring
fee discount recently awarded by mulder
district council but if we are to pay
for parking a large chunk of the mooring
fee discount will be lost
we earn our income taking the public
sailing in the summer months from
october to april we complete the
essential maintenance work on our three
vessels this being carried out entirely
by volunteers
our volunteers are drawn from around
essex they have tools to bring and
are no longer being able to park
adjacent to our work site will cause
some of them to volunteer elsewhere
in the summer sailing monster in the
summer sailing months our barges may be
out for several days at the time and
their volunteer skippers and mates will
need to park their vehicles on hive key
it should be noted that hive key must
remain as a working key for the barge
operators the annual dressing of bard
sales needs to continue unobstructed as
does the movement of materials and
supplies on and off the vessels
we are very concerned about the
practical details as to how the new
parking provision will be managed
the existing permit holders only parking
spaces on hive key are frequently used
by the public and by customers in local
businesses what will change to prevent
the current abuse
more specifically how will the council
prevent non-permit holders from parking
in a space paid for by us
the trust therefore asked that the
chairman of the strategy research
committee needs to delay making a
decision on this new charging policy
until such time as the committee is able
to discuss with the temp saliva trust
exactly how the new parking arrangements
will operate and thank you thank you mr
raymond and obviously we will take that
into consideration when we discuss that
item on the agenda
thank you
okay so we now move on to
agenda item six
which is pay policy statement 2223
found on pages 33 to 40.
uh and uh mr leslie director of
daughters uh with
i was misinstructed on that one
miss cardi over to you on teams
thank you chairman
and i'd like to introduce the pay policy
statement um this is an annual statutory
requirement which describes the approach
of the authority on pay related matters
particularly the renumeration of the
highest and lowest paid staff
it's annually needs to be annually
approved by council and published on our
website by the first of april of the
relevant year
there are specific requirements that
must be published one of which is the
pay multiple which is the ratio between
the highest paid earner in malden's case
of directors and the average earner
earning for the whole workforce
you're seeing with a report that in
malden the highest paid is 3.7 times the
average earnings
the government maximum for this is
recommended to be 20 times above the
average so we do fall well below this
the policy also you'll see sets out that
mdc are committed to paying the real
living wage which is currently nine
pounds 90
to the lowest paid staff and details
also the annual percentage pay increase
the award for this year and next year
have not yet been finalized because it's
still subject to ongoing negotiations
between the unions and the national
joint council
the committee are asked to agree this
statement a head of approval at council
and publication on our website
happy to answer any questions you may
have okay thank you thanks cardi so the
recommendations are set out in the
report and that this is to the council
that the pay policy statement attached
at appendix 1 to this report be adopted
for 2022. do i have a second to please
counselor swain
our members do you have any questions
councillor channel
thank you chairman i wonder if you could
have just asked miss cardi i appreciate
this is the pay policy and i recognize
that the job relation process i think
was 2018 it was looks at again i know
about the director's um renewal
remuneration and everything else um i
think in previous um times and um please
correct me if i'm wrong and it may be it
comes separately um and we do refer to
the um pay the nine pound ninety and
final points
um
where would we find the list of all all
the sort of pay that's allocated
referring to those final points so we
see the whole job evaluation sheet if
you like showing all the relevant grades
and everything
um i know in the past i've seen
something like that but um it's not an
appendices here and i wonder if it
should be or if it's kept somewhere
differently
because
yeah sorry it does refer to sort of pay
and things like that and spinal points
in part of the you know the document
so um there was nothing for me to
correlate
um
those figures too or statements too
this guy is that something that can be
provided to members
it can be yes if i take that away and
provide it
i think that would be useful
sorry
yeah okay thank you mr leslie any other
questions uh cancer suede
yes i knew that uh miss cardi
or the ratio in here is between the the
top pay and the average earnings figure
um
do you have any figure
for the ratio between top pay and the
lowest full-time earning figure
no we don't um but that can be
calculated if that's of interest to
members
again if that's if members find that
useful then uh it could be provided that
would be used for ms cardi
yes yes by always well i would find that
interesting
any other questions
absolutely
can i ask a maybe a silly question why
is it not performance related
is pay increases performance related or
not
i believe local authorities don't work
in that way do they
can i just understand that because
there's the spinal points and you've got
the pain bands and you can move up and
my understanding is that every officer
should have a personal development or
something to discuss issues
and therefore my understanding was
there's also discretion that can be
given to the directors or whoever or
manages to devour some stuff so
is that not an element of unpaid
performance i mean could someone be left
on a ban so it might not be that you
know
but there is no policy for performance
related pay so so so yes that that would
be in a director's or a manager's gift
to say that someone could have a pay
rise and within a banned area but the
council and local authorities do not
have a performance related pay scheme it
doesn't it doesn't happen in local
authorities
am i right miss cardi
you are right yes we have an appraisal
scheme which i think
the member was referring to
and that does monitor performance as
well as a range of other
things
and if there was
an issue with non-performance then it
would be
dealt with under the
capability process from hr
um you are correct in saying that that
counsellors don't uh councils don't have
performance based pay
it's something that is being looked at
by some councils but it's traditionally
never been something that um they adhere
to because of
the other requirements and the policies
in place for councils you could you're
quite correct in saying that they can
be awarded a spinal point at the
discretion of members but it's a very
small
scale that you can do within a grade
usually two or three points
and normally to increase your pay you
would need to go for a promotion and a
vacant
role
thank you miss cardi
any other questions
okay so the recommendation is uh to for
this uh to go to full council can i have
that i agree that please
okay thank you very much thank you ms
cardi
thank you
thank you that was very helpful uh so we
now move to agenda item seven which is
financial pressures and growth
found on page forty one to a hundred i
think this is mr leslie this time
so this report outlines the uh financial
pressures and growth uh that we expect
to experience in the next financial
year this report comes as a result of
consultation with the finance working
group
as well also bringing forward um a
report uh on that front it covers in the
appendices from uh a uh b and c covers
the uh the revenue bids the capital bids
and the repairs and renewal bids
within that
i would point out that an addendum has
been issued in regards to
appendix
a i will just uh highlight what that is
that does relate to the
climate
strategy uh climate action strategy
that's uh on page 45 of the original
document uh the original
uh pack for members uh the essence of
that funding hasn't changed that is to
support the climate action strategy
obviously it's a 30-year strategy um
sorry it's uh runs to 2030
apologies uh and obviously it needs
funding to carry out that strategy
30 years
20 50.
um so it does
does cover that in essence but what has
changed is the uh funding source
around that that we're expecting uh we
had expected some external funding and
that's slightly changed uh from how how
that's going to be
awarded with that body so we're still
we're still going to apply and we're
still hopeful we get some external
funding from that
side of it
but the the ask now has changed to to
fund that action strategy to 83
000 pounds per year we are hopeful that
we will achieve uh 50 match funding for
that which will would reduce but because
that isn't guaranteed uh we aren't
building that in in the budget
currently under these proposals
and the other change around that is
we're looking to base that in in the
budget now we were previously looking to
fund that from uh reserves but from a
sustainability point of view the climate
action work will be ongoing therefore it
seems more prudent to base it in the
budget and recognize that cost
fully
from that side so there is a summary
provided for each area
um
as you can see uh for revenue
which perhaps gives a good breakdown and
again
for repairs and renewals
there are on appendix b from page 47
there are uh much more detailed
packs as well that support that um
that summary
we are asking
this to
be approved
until
until it comes to the next meeting along
with the mtfs what we are asking is that
this is obviously noted and that it does
come back
with the mtfs at a later date
but we wanted to make sure members had
full visibility of what was going on to
build the budget and also have as much
opportunity as possible to input
onto these fronts so happy to take
questions okay thanks leslie so the
recommendations as i set out mr lizzy
says
is uh little one that the financial
pressures and growth bids identified as
part of the 2223 budget setting process
be noted
that the pressures and growth at
dependencies a to c are brought forward
to the next meeting australian resources
committee for recommendation to the
council as part of the medium-term
financial strategy and 22-23 budget do i
have a second to please
counselor durham thank you
members any questions
absolutely
um thank you very much chairman um page
45 uh chairman and this is the item i
was talking about and i will declare my
interest the changing places toilets
and um regarding um what his aim there i
just say that i do welcome that chairman
very much in fact i can't remember when
but i actually did raise this and said
um god it must be years back rather than
months about were we considering that
there was something i was aware of so i
do welcome that very much and i notice
what it says about
um
you know the maintenance of all
successful and securing government
funding i take it to be from that and
i'm not quite sure how we go about that
but that's what i will secure 100k from
government to install those so that's
quite interesting and does that mean
um that covers the whole cost of that
installation
and then on page 46 chairman if i may
there's a couple of entries there which
actually was talk to training sort of
budgets uh one of them to budget support
workforce planning saying we've got a
very limited to train budget to train
staff and then we have the cpd training
for park cemeteries and maintenance
teams budget to insure mandatory
training requirements i may be mistaken
it might be a total different training
um budget stream but i do recall always
we had a members training budget and we
also had officers training budget
was that officer's training budget
purely for attending let's say i don't
know conferences outside of the
authority or was that meant to encompass
items such as this before us tonight so
i'll leave an add-on to that training
budget i'm aware of in the past most
certainly or
it was that purely as i say just for
things outside and it might go to a
seminar or something to help your
personal development so just ask those
questions if i may chairman thank you
very much mr leslie
thank you
uh so changing toilets 100k what would
cover all the install cost et cetera the
only thing we would have is ongoing
maintenance costs although we
there's potential that um places leisure
may pick up some of that in the contract
and recognizing the benefits but i think
it's prudent again that we've put in uh
maintenance costs to ensure that if we
put something in we can maintain it
on the training side of it yesterday
obviously the members budget and there's
a officer's training budget
uh what we're finding it's
it wasn't sufficient at the current
levels to carry carry it uh out all
these extra responsibilities i was
thinking we need to recognize these
mandatory uh costs need to be covered uh
obviously we could reduce um the the
training budget uh by 12k but then of
course we run into two other issues in
terms of actually professional
development um and also keeping the
teams up to date and ensuring that
everyone was sufficiently uh skilled uh
from that side
yes
can you tell me what the overall
training budget is then for self if
you're saying there wasn't enough budget
within the the training budget and hence
why we've now got this coming i would be
interested to know the overall training
budget
for staff and how that may be
appropriated and then these areas that
are going on top obviously
yep so perhaps a bit of background as
well so that's made up we have the
appraisals that we've already talked
about and within that the training needs
of staff are identified
and from that we do have the training
budget
and then the hr team will take into
account all the training that's come
forward
for for development and that will be
assessed uh and prioritized and then put
into a training plan for some of that
there is also corporate training as well
that takes place such as data protection
you know the overall health and safety
and all that side of things so there is
a corporate training which that funds
as well and the hr team do maintain um
that budget as you can imagine uh it can
be uh is often oversubscribed so it does
have to be prioritized and perhaps can
be rolled into the next year if we
identify there are some priorities
that take place so that control is in
place in terms of the actual amount i
would have to double check i have off
the top of my head i think it might be
in the region of 35
000 uh pounds but um
i shall
have to have a look at that i think the
corporate training budget is about 42 in
fact there we go uh 42 000 pounds um
for the corporate training uh budget
which does that but they also uh just
for a complete um transparency there are
actually individual directorate training
budgets um as well uh resources six
thousand planning um four thousand and
customers and communities uh nine
thousand pounds so overall there's about
seventy three thousand pounds uh of
those to cover all the mandatory
training requirements and all those
personal development side of it
very much that's a very full answer
thank you
counselor sam
yeah thank you chairman can i ask mr
leslie if we got any more information
why magnus in the nda have taken a step
back and if obviously it's it's a large
sum of money now uh that were expected
that's for the climate action strategy
post
um is there anywhere else we can go
because um we do need it we all need but
i remember cancer durham saying
something at the last meeting about
tapping in and not basically reinventing
the wheel didn't you counselor durham um
so i'm just very conscious that that's a
great deal of money and i'm a great i'm
sorry i'm being distracted by the noise
out there i've got really difficult
hearing and i can only focus on one
thing and it's absolutely i'm sure
everybody can hear
i'd rather not draw attention to it like
well i'm so sorry but i have difficulty
hearing if this the peripheral noise
it's as simple as that
it's not anyway i've got bad eyesight
and bad hearing i don't do it very well
chairman but there you go so on the
signs of getting older um so um yeah is
there anything else that we actually can
do regarding that so it's not costing
this authority such a large amount of
money even though we know it's very
important
thank you
so is that something we could do a
shared services with another council
which is the approach that we're now
starting to take with particular roles
yes any options we we can
investigate uh originally we had
allocated uh potential funding but the
the funder
changed uh its parameters for applying
for funding so we then had to have to
change them and like say hopefully we
can still access some of that money and
what this uh
funding does is actually put in place a
resource who can actually now look more
fully and devote more of that time to
perhaps looking at other funding sources
et cetera so that certainly would be one
of the goals for that person
can i just come back because i wasn't
thinking about sharing that resource
that wasn't the point of the question it
was actually if there was funding
elsewhere that we could get
because i'm all for supporting this i
think this authority needs to move
forward on the climate action strategy
anyway thank you
the the thing
that this uh authority at times lacked
in the past is is that we create
strategies but don't have anybody to
implement them so i think it is
important that we do resource this
um and that we look to spend the money
and then you know that will then
hopefully bring in other revenues to
support that role um so i think it is
important that we do move forward
okay uh so
uh
can we agree that virus sent members
thank you very much
so we move now on to agenda item eight
which is discretionary fees and charges
2223
pages found on pages 101 to 124
mr leslie
yeah thank you chair
uh the committee received the fees and
charges policy recently and obviously
promised that the detailed fees and
charges will be coming back and this is
the annual report that comes back as a
recommendation to council once again
been through the finance working group
and this report gives members an early
opportunity to review what's come out of
those current uh
discussions within the group um i'm
happy to suggest have a conversation
with officers and they're happy to
propose um to the group that
if agreeable
the
hive key parking we could uh provide
more information as officers and it
could be perhaps uh proved subject to
more information coming forward happy to
uh
i think that would be a useful thing to
defer that to the next meeting yeah
happy subject to to more information
coming forward um but that's something
that we've discussed as officers and
obviously more than happy to provide
that extra information
um around that there is a helpful
summary at um
i appreciate there's quite a lot of fees
and charges um that's come through but
there there is
hopefully a helpful summary provided at
appendix b which actually details where
the changes come some members may uh
wish to focus attention on certain areas
within that summary um but uh thank you
chair thank you very much leslie so the
recommendations are or the regulation is
rather uh to the council that the
detailed fees and charges for 2223 as
set out in appendix a b agreed to have a
second place
yes
okay
and it does concern the
charges are the high and
the significant increase
effectively
existing annual charge being deleted and
new charges being instituted
and one of which is exactly the same as
the
previous one about a significant
increase overall and um
i
take the point made by mr raymond
earlier as the republic
that
we're in a bit of um should we say
piecemeal um
activity in terms of parking and what we
do
and i
i would
like to say see that we maintain the
existing
um
fees
um pending a
um
which was a review of how we see the use
of the high parking
there are two
complications for this one is uh i think
there is some
some
examination of the use of that area
including the word public park
and
it seems to be open to
open to discussion whether there should
be any public parking
down there either on the road
or key
um except of course in relation to
people who live
down behind and the other
complication which we need to bear in
mind is um
the commercial managers
possible
um plans for using some of the
premises there's a
prevailing ones
um
for
additional
commercial purposes which would lead to
another uh
stream of requirement for
parking so i think until we
can
develop a care and plan for who should
be who should have the right to park
down there
um then then we stick with the existing
fee arrangement
okay so you are you putting forward a
recommendation that all the other fees
and charges are agreed and go to full
council other than the parking at the
height at this stage yes
chairman i thought we deferred the
attacking charges anyway so that's going
to come back so take it on board so so
the recommendation will be that we agree
the fees and charges apart from the war
parking which will come back to this
committee
what happened
so so
it won't be agreed at full council until
february anyway
so these this will be agreed at the
budget meeting in february of full
council
so we've so it won't happen till then
anyway
so this particular point will come back
to the next strategy resources committee
meeting after the officers have spoken
to the barge owners um and see whether
there is a
an option to move this forward
when's the next meeting strategy and
sources for the third of february oh so
it's before the budget yes
okay
okay so we're agreeing that the detailed
features and charges are agreed apart
from the wharf parking
and that will come back to the committee
meeting on the third of february
okay
okay council china well i just asked
questions on some of the fees and
charges a lot seemed to remain as were
and then there's increases in other
areas
and i just noticed regarding the malden
promenade park we're changing the
charging there in fact we seem to be
changing the hours as we have done
elsewhere with sort of the two support
we're doing two to five
and um so we delete the two to four hour
charge of six pounds as i see it um
so sorry am i ready that's right i am
right and then we're having the new
charge at six at 6 50. um are we yeah i
think i'm looking at that and then we've
got the all-day charge
um so
have we worked out proportionally the
you know value for money on that or what
we're covering with that and i just
wondered why we're changing the hours
um to go from two to four to two to five
hours do we find two to four isn't a
sensible time frame when we think two to
five is
do we feel more people will stay and go
for that charge and just a couple of
questions there
and um
i hope i'm reading it right very quickly
i'm sorry sorry no we just let's carry
on cancer channel well no i'll end it
there okay
i think yeah i was i was being asked to
call uh miss green see if she's online
um because she may be able to to answer
those questions and could i then just
ask i noticed um you know and i'm all
for tourism so don't get me wrong though
that's partly why the key i'm very
interested to have further consideration
of those matters i think we need to
recognize i'm sure we'll do how
important um tourism is but i noticed um
we got unless i read it wrong that
regarding coaches
um you know i see that we are perhaps
attack not attacking and that's the
wrong word but we're putting onus on
pat's residents who come to pompa of
visitors from outside because i i know
it's a tremendous draw for a lot of
people but actually the coaches i i
couldn't see um any increment
there at all in terms of
um for coaches and that may be because
it wasn't valid in terms of the tourism
but then regarding
resident season tickets
that seemed to change
somewhat quite drastically if i read
that right underneath um resident season
ticket resident season ticket to us per
day a new charge
thank you i think we were bringing them
in in line with the other
to make it similar to other charges in
the town weren't we
yeah
is she there
oh hello
[Laughter]
could you answer those questions for us
certainly the um certainly the change
that are being proposed is to um
certainly for the visitor for the
visitor permits
um
is to bring them into line with the
other car parking charges um in the town
centre so we do have different rates of
permits so the intention of this review
is to essentially bring those all into
line so that we have some consistency
across the car parks so that is the main
um
the main approach and with regards to
the highs i think there have been a
number of questions that have been
raised quite valid questions and i think
that's something we would like to to
bring a report back to members with um
having taken on board
a number of the comments that have been
made um and bring a separate report back
on that so i think that the hive is one
that we did want to return to
which obviously i know i know when we
discussed the
car parking at the prom
the long term uh yeah season ticket we
were talking about making it a bit
cheaper than what it would be in the
high street is that is that what's come
forward
um
essentially it's really trying to bring
them back into line because there's a
very big variant between the car parks
in the high street and the um and the
prom and so what we're trying to do is
to bring those more into line and then
not to be such a large variation in the
cost okay thank you
coaches
do we charge for coaches and and
is it is it going up by inflation
um chairman i believe it is going up by
slightly more than inflation um so there
is an increase proposed for the for the
coaches as well
okay
i think all fees and charges are going
up via inflation or an inflationary
amount
um there are some fees and charges that
are going up
at a higher rate but all our fees and
charges will be get will be going up by
inflation or more
am i reading it wrong then it looked to
me like the coaching part
um
7 30 20 21 22 and 7
down thirty
am i reading the wrong line that was
saying twenty two
twenty three i thought it looked the
same to me that's why the question was
like i could have read this wrong
because when you're reading these tables
your eyes can go all over the place
just looking at the report there i think
the relevant page is
i've got 111 by the pdf which i think is
the actual yeah 111 is about page about
about middle of the way
moulding from um there you've got a car
and then under that you have coach up to
two hours
seven pound thirty uh and then last year
seven pound thirty and over two hours
thirteen thirty so so now this
from from the report there on page 11
there's no
changes to those particular uh charges
have have come through
this report
we've made changes regarding residents
i'm not saying that they should be
increased i just wanted to understand
the rationale in the differences than
why we felt that code company
might not necessarily be subjected to an
inflation charge
okay
and
yeah so again we can amend that
cancer stem
yeah thank you chairman am i a little
bit concerned that we're trying to put
one size fits all um car parks in
different areas of the district cannot
in my view should command the same um
level of
charges
because especially for high turnover in
town centres it's different for when you
go to the prom
i just think we're very very careful
that we don't just turn around and say
like we're going to charge x amount for
every car park that we own i have i have
a big concern about that it's a bit late
now but i mean
i actually don't agree with it thank you
okay
yeah
and that's that's the discussion that
we've had previously
okay chairman you keep saying you've had
a discussion previously is it been
previous at this or is it previous
meetings
the finance working group which you
attended council i think it's
please try not to be patronising to me
chairman but yes i think you are but the
thing is it's important that we discuss
it in an open forum
will you please stop interrupting me
it's bad
are you going to allow us to be said
carry on are you going to allow that to
be said chairman
that is that is bespeeching dispatching
my reputation and my husband i have
attended this camp chrissy
christie give your kid
thank
can you please stop interrupting me as
well when i speak it's bad if you do not
allow people to speak when they actually
do want to i'm elected too
councillor morris
councillor stamp no forget it and i'm
not going to be abused by somebody
sitting in a gallery either
okay
so if we move on then in terms of the
recommendation that this is approved by
full council
um apart from the car parking at the
wharf which will come back to this
meeting on february the third
can we if that agreed that by our ascent
and the coach charging will be amended
yeah
yeah okay thank you councillor channel
so move on to a gender item nine which
is supply estimates vermont and
procurement exemptions and use of
reserves
pages one two five two one two eight
uh mr leslie
i think he shares this is a regular
report that comes forward to comply with
our financial regulations uh in this
report uh it just brings forward
environment supplement estimates uh
exemptions and use of reserves all to be
noted um for the committee in the courts
of the financial regulations uh you see
we've had um
one one environment um taking place
there to allow some health and safety
works to to be carried out
um and we've also had um
supplementary estimates uh as well to
come forward uh and that's where it's
four supplemental instruments as well
also partly to do with
health and health and safety taking
place
um
three procurement exemptions uh
as well and uh one draw down from the uh
reserves for uh commercial
feasibility
uh happy to take questions really on
those okay so the recommendations are
set out in the report as follows and
please note that the in the original
report the paragraph numbers were
incorrect
so they have there has been an amendment
sent out on that so little one that the
environment has detailed in paragraph
three point three point one had the
report be noted that supplement
measurements estimates as detailed in
paragraph 3.4.1 of the report to be
noted little three that the three
procurement exemptions as detailed in
the program 3.5.1 of the report to be
noted and little four that the drawdown
from reserves has detailed in paragraph
3.6.1 of the reward be noted do i have a
second to please counselor sway
members any comments
oh okay can we agree that via sent
thank you very much
so we now move on to agenda item 10
uh supplementary estimate splash park
found on pages one two nine two one
three four uh miss green the customer
community and casework manager i believe
you're presenting this
you chairman
um so this report is coming forward for
a request for two um additional
supplementary estimates for one is the
revenue estimate of ten thousand pounds
and that's for the cost of electrical
work to the splash park um and then a
further supplementary estimate which is
capital um in terms of 140 000 and
that's for the cost of the resurfacing
work to the splash park
um so i'd just like to take members
through just a few key points of the
report
the
splash park was originally funded
externally in 2004 so we did receive
full funding
and the splash park opened in 2006
and generally the surface of a splash
park would be expected to last around
about 10 years so the splash park
surface that we have got has been
maintained and has lasted well in excess
of that sort of 15 years
as members are aware the splash park
is
part of the
district
it's very well used by visitors and our
own residents
we have identified in the last year that
the surface has significantly degraded
and there were some repair works done
last year but we have had a consultant
and review the service to the splash
park um and he has concluded that it is
unrealistic to be able to repair it any
further and it does need to be
resurfaced in full so that's why we're
coming forward with this request
um just to give a little background to
members so the splash park um runs at a
break even point each year
but going forward we have highlighted
some further opportunities um to try and
improve um the success of cash flow um
and this would be within our existing um
approach so it wouldn't necessarily be
about increasing the charges per person
but reviewing the charging policy around
who is charged to enter on the splash
park
so that will be reviewed next year as
part of the reopening
the bottom line is that without
resurface and the splash pocket is a
health and safety hazard we wouldn't be
able to reopen it the next year so what
we are looking for is in total as i said
150 000 which is a 10 000 for the
electrical work and revenue and 140 000
pounds capital
and just just for information as members
are aware
we did have some operating difficulties
last year
and so to increase the resilience of the
splash park and in the day-to-day
running we are looking at working in
partnership
um
but that's just a bit of an aside for
members to be aware
i think that the the main points are
that without the additional funding next
year we would not be able to open the
splash park
okay
thank you very much for screen uh so the
recommendations are set out on the
report are little ones a supplementary
revenue estimate of 10 000 pounds for
the cost of the electrical work to the
splash bar is approved
the two that's a supplementary catabol
estimate of 140 000 pounds for the cost
of the resurfacing work to the splash
park is approved do i have a second to
please
uh counselor thompson
any questions at all
so i had counselor channel first
thank you chairman um
i wonder if i'm sure my screen will
answer this um
and in the report it states it and
you've actually made reference to it so
it's about the maintenance work was done
if you like resurfacing which we had
about three year period
and now we've got further degradation
deterioration we have to do the whole
lot was it in any way because those
works were insufficient or substandard
because it seemed or were they just sort
of a holding maintenance type of thing
because obviously we're now finding
we've got to do substantial maintenance
and of course um i have a view the
splash park as we know is a great
visitor tourist attraction it's iconic
it's a great asset i mean people come
from south well further than suffolk
actually because they've got nothing
like it so i'm just interested in that
though the expenditure we had for that
repair that was done which seems to be
you know only a year's worth
screen
um
thank you chairman um the running
repairs that were done last year we had
hoped would last more than 12 months
but unfortunately they haven't
it wasn't anything to do with the
standard of work it's simply that the
splash park surface is beyond its its
kind of life
expectancy it's now 15 years old and
normally the maximum it would be it
would normally last would be 10 years so
i think it we have just eeked out the as
the maximum use we can of it okay thank
you
councillor boyce
thank you chairman um i fully support
both these um recommendations
um uh i remember the history and why the
splash park is there
and it
it was for the youngsters of the
district and from what mrs channel says
from the rest of the world
um
but i've always thought
that within the pricing policy we should
be building in
a
sinking fund
and if we're going to look at the policy
next year perhaps that can be taken into
account now i know you've then got to
offset that against the cost of
uh
uh
of the
users
um
but if we and the public want to retain
this then that's the price that's got to
be paid thank you chairman i think
that's something again that uh mr scream
we talked about and we have said that
that should be built into future budgets
is that correct having a sync fund yeah
that's correct that's
so that that will happen counsellor
voice that's the stamp
yeah thank you i canceled the voice
jumped onto my wagon there a bit because
that's what i was going to say but also
could it be linked with the prom
management plan it's been talked about
at this council for quite some time now
to have a prom management plan and i
think if you're looking into the splash
park it's an integral and an important
part of the prom so can we not look at
it all with the management plan thank
you
mr holmes is looking nodding at me he
knows i've been banging on and banging
on about this for quite some time and i
think it's really important that gets
off the ground and the prom management
plan also then can include us come over
to burnham on crouch and look at the
riverside park as well i think it's
really important we actually move and go
in a slightly different direction and i
certainly agree with councillor boyce
and chana regarding the recommendation
chairman thank you just to confirm i've
got an officer meeting next week to
start that discussion around management
plans you're quite right we have a plan
for the prom we should have a plan for
riverside park and our cemeteries and we
will start with prom park because there
are a number of the larger activities
but that debate will be happening and
we'll take that forward
thanks james uh cancer durham
yeah thank you chairman chairman i i
care everything that's been said about
the the value of the splash park um
you know it has been a terrific asset to
us in the past um and
you know i i think with the benefit of
hindsight
the um
the patch up job we did was probably not
not the best route we
we we took it was really just a
um you know
literally a
patch up and
you know a bit of
stuff here you know material here and
there you know i'm a firm believer in
you know do it right do it once um
and uh you know there's obviously a cost
implication to that
but as you know you know this the the um
splash park is also being discussed by
the leisure contract working group which
may uh assist the
profitability of that particular
operation but um i totally support this
uh this item thank you
sorry cancer don't counsel thomas
i'm getting ahead of myself
oh thank you chairman um
yeah i was wondering i know there have
been
discussions in
i've lost track of which meeting about
pricing for adults accompanying children
is that
being looked at at some point because
there's not very many things people get
to go free because they haven't what's
going on are we going to start charging
for adults
um
jen we are looking at reviewing the the
current policy which at the moment means
that any any adult with a a person under
16 essentially can gain access to the
splash park without paying um but we are
looking to review that policy and look
at perhaps a lower age bracket where we
would um
allow
adults to come in and not pay and not
necessarily for the older children so
that's part of the charging policy that
we will look at next year okay thank you
thank you okay thanks so you members can
we agree that via ascent
okay thank you very much
thank you very much for screaming
uh so now move on to agenda item 11
review of memorials in cemeteries parks
and open spaces policy
mr hopes
thank you chairman um as you'll see from
the report we've encountered a number of
difficulties at an operational level
relating to the management of memorial
benches
the purpose of this report is to
recommend an alternative scheme which
offers customers choice but also be more
manageable with the council we also look
into a new inspection and repair regime
for those existing memorial benches and
it's also detailed within the report
this is taking a lot of thought and care
because of our customers and we
obviously know this is very emotive for
those people involved um we do have our
cemeteries officers here debbie hurry
this evening who's actually drafted this
report and would be happy to assist
members there's leaving any questions
and uh i hope the problem must make a
decision thank you mr holmes uh so the
recommendations are sat out and the
report has as follows and this is to the
council that little one that the seller
benches as individual items available to
purchase
which are then installed in our parts
open spaces cease that little two that's
a new scheme to be introduced where
customers can lease a plaque on a bench
for five year periods little three that
the updated memorials in cemeteries
parks and open spaces policy appendix c
to be agreed and implemented no later
than the 1st of april 2022 do i have a
seconder
councillor swain
uh members any questions
counselor boyce
thank you chairman um
earlier
we deferred an item and basically i'm
asking
that this item be deferred for the same
reason the other item was deferred for
consultation with those people
that
are closely involved with the cemeteries
we have
two friends groups with the cemeteries
and their information to me
is that they haven't had any
consultation over this
and
i'm sure mr holmes or somebody will
correct me if if that is wrong but that
is my information so my proposal is that
this items be deferred to the next
meeting to allow consultation with the
the friends groups okay and as an aside
can i ask
what's happening to our friends groups
um in the district
generally if they still exist
uh and perhaps we should have
some future information on what french
groups are operating and how effective
they are so thanks chairman mr james
german can i second that proposal please
okay
thank you chairman um i think in terms
of more general question about friends
groups i think we should revisit i mean
french groups um come and go and
depending on these other issues and that
there are a number of core groups that
still exist so i think it would be
fairly straightforward for us to give
you a status on that and of course
they're an important part of management
plans as well so when we look at our
plans we'll be able to make sure we
reference them so happy to commit to do
that um but i think would be useful
perhaps at this stage if our cemeteries
officer could just give a little
background about um particularly around
the friends groups around cemeteries and
obviously the level of consultation she
may have undertaken to draft this report
okay
hello
oh oh you are
i moving been speaking with the friends
of bloomberg cemetery which is quite a
new group and obviously with a pandemic
it has been difficult to have as much
involvement as we would like
and i appreciate that there would be
interest in both friends groups it's
also important to say
that we're not looking to take away
anything that anybody already has
and this is about introducing a scheme
that will work be consistent moving
forward and working with people who
already have benches and the
expectations that they have
okay
uh cancer dora
yeah thank you chairman chairman i i i
have some sympathy um you know the
memorial best benches are are a great
idea
and when somebody uh or family is newly
bereaved they they go to the cemetery
and they look at the benches and they
think oh that'd be a nice thing to have
but if we did it for absolutely
everybody we'd have
thousands of benches i had exactly the
same uh
problem in my previous uh
incumbency
um and you you just have to draw a line
at some stage
um we also have the case you know when
somebody is newly bereaved and they get
the bench and they they go there very
frequently
um
in the fullness of time
some families not all certainly
tend to lose a bit of the initial
interest and and
so i i think we need to assess
the correct number of benches that the
cemeteries can accommodate
and if the best way of
providing some form of remembrance um
be it plaque on the bench or a plaque on
on a memory wall or whatever um we
should look at ways of doing it but i i
it's
regrettably
it is not practical to have an
individual bench for each um deceased
person
um because there would just be hundreds
and hundreds of benches
who inevitably fall into disrepair and
and look awful
so this is something and i i would be
happy that this is debated wider um
but it's not you know i'm not being a
killjoy said i've you know got recent
bereavements in the family and and it's
something that is of
of key interest but we we have to be
realistic and we can't uh
put benches everywhere much the same on
the on the heybridge basin and places
like that i'm sure you could more or
less line the coastline with benches
from the people that you know want them
there but you have you have to draw a
line somewhere
and and i agree councillor durham this
is a common sense approach
is my view of this particular policy
councillor channel
chairman um well councillor boyce and i
are thinking like on more than one thing
tonight obviously and i would say i
fully support that proposal
and i do appreciate that a lot of work
has gone into this report and i value
that but there were a number of areas i
was going to question i have to say i
have had representation
from a concerned resident i don't know
if any other member has i've suggested
actually they
make sure other members are aware
particularly ward members and they've
raised some very valid points and
questions because of knowledge they have
got a bench a family bench with a plaque
and i i've got to say that i'm one of
those um i go along um you know into the
parks like other people um i go um in
the cemeteries not so frequently but i
mean our land that we own
and in other places and i actually one
of those that do tend to sit on the
benches that have the plaques and i like
to sit there and actually i find it
quite heartwarming i welcome perhaps a
maintenance scheme because i am aware
from the representation i've had that
they've done some of the maintenance
themselves and when they thought perhaps
there was the maintenance scheme that
the council applied so i do think
there's some areas that really need some
sort of clarity for members and greater
understanding and i do agree
wholeheartedly that this is a an area
certainly the friends group i was going
to make that point i do think we need
some consultation with users and
residents we used to have a citizen
panel as well i think it's on something
like this because this is very very
emotive as well
and um i think we've all lost uh people
in our families and gone down various
routes to remember that person
and
you know this plaque renewal um every
five years um i've got some questions
around that so thank you chairman i
won't linger anymore or add any more
because there's other ones to come but i
appreciate the hard work but i i do
agree that we need to perhaps have
further considerations on another report
or and certainly consult elsewhere
supposedly did you do any comments on
that at all
um i think the difficulty that we have
as a local authority is up until this
point we haven't had a scheme for any of
the benches outside of the cemetery
department and we're trying to have a
consistent approach and as you're
rightly pointing out in
current burial areas or at promenade
park or riverside park there'll be high
demand for benches and how do we service
all of those people without having
more benches than their space and if you
think um
typically in the cemeteries a row
of graves there'll be about 10 to 15
graves and if everybody wants a plaque
we're having to turn people
away which is really bad because we want
everyone to be able to enjoy the scheme
equally and by leaving a plaque on a
bench more people can enjoy the scheme
whereas at the moment it's a select few
people in certain areas
and this is why we're looking to change
the approach to make it a more
consistent approach available to more
people
thank you uh council shawnee
um thank you chairman um i have um
i am in agreement with um councillor
durham
um i think benches are the first thing
that people think of when they want to
commemorate somebody
um and i think um as a council we should
give them alternatives
um and and really think about this um
and i think memory balls um and such
like are a really good idea um you know
they're they're used um in cities um you
know throughout europe that that type of
thing so i definitely think that we
should give people um
these alternatives
you know as opposed to filling the place
with them benches which which of course
it you know it is is not possible so
thank you chairman thank you council
shawnee and i totally agree council
swain
yes thank you chairman
um
having been involved with um setting up
a cemetery myself
and i'm conscious of the um
the problems involved in such a
sensitive area and of course
particularly when one's trying to change
the situation it's always best to
start as you mean to go on
um
uh it's obviously important to
what you say advertise this um widely so
that um
everybody is aware of um what is being
proposed or that possible
changes are afoot
but at the end of the day um there has
to be as uh i think
councillor darren was
implying there has to be some control
and and discipline
of the the whole situation
um and therefore there has to be there
has to be rules and um
which are in
which people
are aware of or made aware of in advance
and this applies to all the aspects of
um memorials in in cemeteries
and and that's the difficulty that in
the past they weren't made aware of
those things and and people then think
that it's their bench when it's not
always their bench which is the issue
that we're now trying to resolve
councillor hull
um with all all the trees that we need
to be growing at the moment um what
about a woodland area somewhere
is that
i think we do have trees planted don't
we counsel that
also
we're doing that at the cemetery already
yes yes
yeah again that's a sort of proposal
that we can look at in terms of the
things in the future i think that's what
we're saying aren't we chairman you know
by going to the friends their friends
groups have probably got ideas as well
that with all due respect we might not
have thought out so i think
by having that sort of consultation
interaction um there could be other
ideas that come forward to assist with
mr holmes
chairman i think absolutely we can go
back to the friends groups and have uh
their discussion but i think
it's an important sort of principle what
we're trying to do is we'll be more
inclusive here and it will give more
people an opportunity yeah but it's not
the only way people will be able to
memorialize and as i say there are a
number of options you know from tree
planting some other ideas that we're
bringing forward but i think to help us
we've got a waiting list we can't move
forward
we can't keep putting benches in so what
we really need to do is change that
method but that doesn't mean that's the
only way forward but if we can move
forward with the benches and then keep
other ideas going forward then obviously
we can and bring that back to members as
well and and this is all about moving
forward cancer stump yeah thank you i
take on board what mr holmes and debbie
said
but i think it needs to be done properly
as a strategy we're looking at changing
the policy i can't remember the date was
it 2017 when it was renewed or looked up
previously i can't remember so forgive
me
um but i think it needs to be done as a
whole i don't think it should be
piecemeal i don't think we should be
breaking one off and doing the benches
now i think for the sake of speaking to
the friends of other cemeteries
um i think we actually do need to speak
to them there's nothing wrong um
with actually looking at i think the
word that um accounts for shaunicy was
referring to or the possibility was a
and i've looked it up a a column barium
which is something which it's like a
wall where you can actually go and if
we're going to put some sort of
investment and we're going to have
something in the cemeteries or we have
an area you could do that with some sort
of canopy or something that that could
be closed off so you're not out in the
rain et cetera et cetera i think we just
need to look at this as a bigger a
bigger piece of work uh i don't mean to
take loads of um
debbie's time up uh or richard holmes's
time up but i don't i don't think it's
something we should just
m i personally agree with councillor
boyce it should be deferred and i think
more work should be done on it and it
could come back it's not a massive piece
of work i'm sure the other cemetery
group would be willing to to meet quite
urgently and i think it's a it's a
policy that needs to be treated with
great sensitivity
and it needs to be done properly and not
you know headlines modern district
council are going to do this without
speaking to anybody i think it really
needs to be handed handle said
sensitively thank you mr holmes
general i think there will be time for
debbie to do that piece of consultation
with the cemeteries groups and perhaps
return this report in february i do
think we need to make a decision because
we have that log jam the customers
obviously are needing a service as well
so i think if we can turn around as
quickly as we can seek the views from
the friends group and represent that to
you so you've got that knowledge before
you make a decision that would be
possible cancer voice
chairman um i haven't got a view one way
or the other um on this um but i am
aware
that authorities get into trouble when
they make decisions without consult
proper consultation i don't know what
proper consultation in this case is but
i just assumed that
as we've got these friends groups that
and they've
say they haven't had consultation
although the officer says that there has
been some with malden um
and as an aside
i don't agree with plastic benches
i think if we go woodlands we could then
perhaps make
make benches out of the woods that we
grow
again it would be i think yeah having
benches appropriate to the environment
but again that's the sort of thing that
we can look at in terms of the
maintenance
uh cancer durham
yeah i'm mean chairman
we shouldn't just rush into that we need
to be mindful of the uh the groups who
devote their their time free of charge
uh to look after the cemeteries and of
course it's wider than just benches you
know in the past we've had issues with
um
memorial adornments night lights all
sorts of things that that people tend to
put
for their for their own best reasons but
are not universally accepted by other
call them inmates but um you know the
um so you know it's very important that
we have fairly strict policies of
what is and what isn't permitted in in
our
in our cemeteries as well as the benches
so you know let's as i said let's do it
right and let's do it once okay thank
you counselor stamp yeah thank you
chairman uh and also i think there's
been discussions had
about uh on the prom to have i can't
remember what they're called the stone
where where people can have the memorial
stones laid in a path i mean we're
actually looking at that idea so this is
why i'm reticent about trying to rush
something through because there's a
there's lots more ideas that need to be
encompassed and brought into a policy as
far as i'm concerned and that could be
one of the things because that then
would move with the other directions and
and policies and the way this council
wanted to move to to develop the prom
and enhance what we've got at the prom
so i think it's important thank you
i think it depends on on on whether
officers think that we can do things as
separate items or whether that does need
to be one-hot policy and and maybe if
this comes back then we can have that
discussion uh mr holmes
yeah yeah absolutely as i said there are
a number of ways people can memorialized
and uri it's not just at the cemeteries
and yes there are other activities i
think we can do a sort of a summary
report but what i wouldn't want to do is
get us
too delayed in looking at everything
rather than focusing on what we think is
the pressing need around the cemeteries
but i think if we covered um the views
from the french group we also set out
potentially what other um normal
illustration might be coming in the
pipeline going forward so at least we
can take that first step in in the
context of everything else that would be
really helpful to us just to undo that
sort of log jam at the moment
what about people that already bought
you know branches could we not get a
view from them as well because they're
the the seasons of the scheme the
logistics of that would be
it would be logistically difficult um
and i guess it's whatever's on offer at
the time so what was offered at the time
was buy a bench and that's your bench
but i think what we're saying is we're
moving away into something different now
and doing it who i've been approached by
what happened was an article appeared
um
uh
more than nub news
and of course they've seen that and
you know it's kicked it off
and raised concerns and because they
have purchased a bench and got family
you know plaques and things like that so
yeah it's important i think
so we do already have a recommendation
on the table
um
which is that we were referring this to
the council
so the the initial recommendation still
stands
are we going to agree that
but
that's why i'm saying there's already
there's already a recommendation on the
table that was second i think by
councillor swain i can't remember now um
so that recommendation that i read
earlier is already on the table
counselor boyce's recommendation is not
on the table at the moment because of
the earlier recommendation
so we have to vote on that first
recommendation before we can go to
councillor boyce's recommendation
so
our it is the first recommendation
agreed or refused so all those in favor
please show
so the first recommendation was to the
council that the sale of benches as
individual items available for purchase
which are then installed in our parks
and open spaces cease that a new scheme
be introduced where customers can lease
a plaque on a bench for five years
periods that the updated memorials and
sandwiches parks and open basis policy
be agreed and implemented no later than
the 1st of april 2022
so that is the recommend
it's on the table at the moment
now i've moved in an amendment to that
um uh chairman that
that doesn't actually
negate that okay but saying
for consultation okay
so that's the third of february would
you be able to do that by the third of
february mr holmes
it's tight depending on the the scale of
um if it's just about dealing with the
the french groups but if we went wider
than that it would take us obviously
more time i think is as soon as possible
so if it if say so that so we will add a
additional recommendation that this is
uh the a discussions held with the
friends groups of the cemeteries for the
item to come back on the 3rd of february
yeah
okay is that agreed for our ascent
okay and then it will go to full council
hopefully
[Laughter]
okay
thank you very much
[Laughter]
next time councillor thompson
so we now move on to agenda item 12 uh
to approval to to designate the
woodfield cottages conservation area and
adopt the woodfield cottage's local
listed building consent order found on
pages 151-256
mr howson specialist heritage
conservation officer over to you
good evening
good evening
uh in september last year this committee
authorised the public consultation on
two proposed initiatives relating to
woodfield cottages in haybridge this um
unique victorian settlement of concrete
industrial workers houses
the first initiative is the designation
of a conservation area in recognition of
the area's special architectural and
historic interests
and the second initiative is the
adoption of a local listed building
consent order which would grant
automatic consent for a range of
sympathetic alterations
the
public consultation took place between
the 30th of september and the 11th of
november
as part of which every resident was
written to
and the proposals were widely publicized
the response has been overwhelmingly
positive
each of the responses received is
summarized in appendix 4 to the report
there was unanimous support for the
conservation area designation and uh
positive feedback on the accompanying
character's statement
which is appendix one to the report
most respondents were enthusiastic about
the enhancement opportunities identified
in the character statement and some
suggested further opportunities um such
as underground electricity cables and
the reinstatement of traditional style
lamp posts so in response some of those
works have been added to the wish list
of potential enhancements set out in the
statement
um only one respondent did not support
the proposed local list of early consent
order
and that was the victorian society who
are a charity campaigning for the
preservation of victorian architecture i
think they worried whether the order
would be prescriptive enough
um however after
this committee report was submitted
um conor mitchell of the victorian
society emailed on the 22nd of december
confirming his view that in fact the
order's specifications and conditions
are clear enough and that he
wouldn't have concerns about the
disability consent order being
implemented
he explained that initially his comments
were based
um on not wishing to support something
that the wider conservation world may
have concerns about but in fact no other
conservation bodies have raised any
concerns
and indeed historic england had
supported the proposals so it seems that
that lack of support from the victorian
society initially was stemmed from
an abundance of caution rather than any
specific aspect of the draft order
and the caution is perhaps
understandable since what we are doing
here is quite pioneering
very few other local authorities in the
country have adopted local list of any
consent orders and this would be the
first of its type in east anglia
um at the other end of the spectrum one
of the respondents who didn't object the
order in principle did express the view
that its terms were perhaps too
prescriptive and that it should be
broadened to include other types of work
such as solar panels on the buildings
but it's important to remember that the
order
won't be imposing any restrictions it
will be taking restrictions away but
only for specific types of alteration
which we are confident
will preserve or enhance the special
interest of the buildings um alterations
which would potentially harm the
character of buildings such as solar
panels are best dealt with on a
case-by-case basis through the usual
list of building consent process
and of course depending on the success
of the order the council might consider
broadening the terms of it
in the future if that was considered
appropriate
um
if the committee agrees to designate the
conservation area and adopt the localist
verdict consent order
then obviously all owners and interested
parties will be written to again along
with the required legal notices
and details will be posted on the mdc
website okay
um
yeah thank you very much mr helsin
uh so the recommendations are you didn't
have anything else to say did you do it
i didn't talk to you too soon
uh so the recommendations are set out in
the report are as follows the little one
that the woodfield cottages conservation
area is designated uh little two that
the woodfield cottage's local listed
building consent order is adopted can i
have a second to please
counselor durham
uh and councillor durham you were the
first person with your hand up yeah
thank you thank you chairman um
mr house and another excellent reporter
excellent bit of work
you know uh we we've become very used to
your really
interesting
um appendices i mean it's absolutely
fascinating um you know this particular
part of haybridge is pretty unique
uh and i totally support but it should
be preserved in as close to a condition
as it was original
um as possible
um
you know we need to prevent incongruous
extensions and additions wherever
possible i know there are already some
there but you know we have to live with
what we've got
um
you know i wouldn't like to see it get
too chintzy if you know what i mean
that's not a technical word but um
uh i i just said i totally support this
um because it is an iconic part of of
haybridge as a
village and and it recognizes the
history uh the uh the um
economic history of haybridge and indeed
of malden and the wider area so well
done thank you very much i think chintz
is victorian isn't it uh mr halsen
uh councillor shawnee
thank you chairman um i also would like
to congratulate um mr house and on this
wonderful report um it's really really
interesting and i've thoroughly enjoyed
reading it um and i just have um
something
just an idea that came into my mind that
it would be nice for this council to
think about maybe um presenting um
printed
reports to the residents of woodfield
cottages i just thought that might be
rather a nice gesture and be great uh
you know to towards getting them on side
for um you know the things that need to
be done to these cottages thank you
chairman thank you councillor sean mr
houston has material been presented to
the owners
uh
yes it has but my intention was to print
hard copies of the conservation area
document too
and to hand deliver them to the owners
as well as emailing them
does that fit our climate change policy
uh council channel
well thank you
i'm gonna echo what council counseling
council donald said and just to say
actually i always feel sorry for mr
house and because his reports are so
good you come to the committee and we
see his praises and uh
i think we all find it difficult then to
ask any searching questions or challenge
of you so
i feel a bit sorry in one way that it's
so good we don't really sort of
challenge too much because i think you
say it all actually and i just don't
care what everyone else has said but
maybe in the future at least something
else so we sort of questioned something
uh
councillor thompson
is this going to be mutual pressure yes
i think well no it's mr house and
appreciation yeah exactly you know i'd
like to add my thanks but also
congratulations that you know in another
area malden leads the way thanks to the
work he's done but you know this isn't
the first and i'm sure it won't be the
last thing malden's done first and
thank you very much mr house and for
coming up with this project and
for the reports i i know it helps that
their lovely houses and so on and not
drains or something but
um you know the reports are a pleasure
to read and thank you okay thank you
chip uh so can we agree that via ascent
okay
that's mr house if you stay online
because you're next again aren't you i'm
sorry
yeah
a clarification tonight i didn't see
your house
um yes when you mention um
improvements um in some cases they may
be paid for by the residents but for
general improvements such as the street
lighting and so on do you um foresee
most of this being
funded by grants from various sources
well i've got a
meeting with historic england uh later
this month um because
we
should be able to apply for a
conservation area partnership scheme um
uh and it's something i've been
discussing with historic england
informally but we can't really explore
the parameters of it fully until we're
designated a conservation area so
assuming you approve the conservation
area
tonight um i i have a meeting with
historic england later this month to
discuss what they might consider grant
funding towards and that that may
include um uh public work realm
improvements um
as well as
work to individual properties okay
okay so go back to the uh recommendation
can we agree that virus sent members
okay thank you very much
so you know move on to ice number three
which is the approval of the molden
district heritage at risk register 2022
found on pages 2672320
mr houston
yes well this
report
uh seeks approval to publish
the malden district heritage risk
register 2022
um a draft of which is appended
to the item
the document is an inventory of each of
the historic buildings in the district
currently regarded as at risk of
deterioration or loss
uh the primary aim of the register is
simply to highlight the plight of these
buildings to current owners and local
communities and encourage their
immediate care and future conservation
um
the first few pages of the document
illustrate examples of recent repair
work to neglected buildings across the
district
and
while
there are quite a lot of bit historic
buildings in the district that are in a
vulnerable position 34 sites identified
in total
there are encouraging efforts by
passionate locals to rescue some of
these buildings
um burnham on proud president john boyce
has just set up a heritage company and
assembled a team of volunteers to rescue
the king's wharf jetty
which is an important historic feature
of burnham's waterfront and his features
on the front page of the
draft register
similarly the raf bradwell bay
preservation group um hopes to recruit a
volunteer workforce and seek grant
assistance for the restoration of the
1930s bombing range observation tower
which is a structure near saint peter's
chapel in broadway on scene
um the stone mari's great war aerodrome
trust and their army of volunteers have
been continuing their good work uh
recently applying a bespoke lime slurry
coat to protect the brickwork of the
extremely rare buildings which survive
on that site um our real uh local
heritage champion the roofer rob deering
recently repaired the leaking valley at
haybridge basin chapel
completely free of charge and out of
love for the building
and i believe the newly formed heybridge
parish uh habit basin parish council
is exploring what it can do to help
bring that building back into use
um
major repair work funded by historic
england has hugely improved the
condition and prospects of creeksy place
one of the most important elizabethan
mansions in in essex
a building which has been on the risk
register since 1993
by far the longest suffering historic
building in the district um and that
important recent work won this year's
conservation design awards
um
among the new additions to register uh
are those
locally listed buildings in bradwell on
sea including the world war ii airfield
buildings which are likely to be
destroyed if the proposed power station
goes ahead
and now we are designating the woodfield
cottages conservation area i want to add
that straight away to the risk register
to highlight the challenges that area
faces and hopefully support an
application for grant funding from
historic england
um and number 127 woodfield colleges
which is in a very poor condition i
think merits its own entry on the
register and i've been in dialogue with
the owner um and they've agreed to
instruct some urgent repairs which are
due to take place imminently
um so if the committee approves the risk
register all the owners who have already
been in correspondence with about the
sort of at-risk status of their building
will be sent a copy and will be it will
be published on the nbc website
and a press release uh issued
okay thank you mr thousand so the
recommendations are set out in the
report is as follows
that the publication of the malden
district heritage at risk register 2022
be approved do i have a second to please
councillor stamp
and members any questions for mr house
uh councillor swain
uh yes thank you chairman i'm i'm
particularly concerned about the
the trestle viaduct of wiccan bishops
which um
the owner is essex county council
um and uh it's in a very bad state and
um
i i
want to ask mr hausen
um
is anything really going to be done to
preserve that um is there a viable
option for
putting it into
a reasonable state
and perhaps more should be made of it
by the county council as
as a scheduled monument
it is very obscure
as a as such an important um item
mr houser
yes i absolutely agree it's a very
important i think unique um uh survival
um
county council last undertook a major
scheme for repair in the mid 1990s um
and sadly the building has structures
considerably deteriorated since then i
am in regular uh contact with um
officers at the county council and they
have just recently commissioned a
condition survey and a repair schedule
of the structure um just last year
and that's being used to inform options
for viable
schemes of repair
so it
it's on their agenda
is all i can say
okay thank you mr houston uh councillor
durham
yeah thank you thank you very much
indeed um
i my concerns over this is that by
labeling these some of these properties
as being at risk it does place
considerable onus on the owners of these
and they can be forced to bring them
into a
more satisfactory or safer condition
i i'm looking at some of the barns and
we do
on occasions have situations where
a dilapidated barn is brought forward
for
conversion to um a domestic dwelling and
the argument is that that is the only
way that it that it can be
saved as a building um
and and preserved them which i think is
a
dangerous precedent because it
encourages
owners of such buildings to leave them
to fall into disrepair in order to get
um a a domestic dwelling uh permission
um the other thing you know i'm slightly
the the um
the the wall at braxton is is a constant
um
issue um
largely because cars keep bashing into
it and as well as
items getting stolen from it
um and um
that has got well probably one of the
most significant cost implications for
the owner of the bratz of the state um
running you know well into seven figures
and unfortunately although he got the uh
the enabling development of the houses
um
he then got stuck for a capital gains
bill which has wiped out a significant
chunk of it so i'm not quite sure how
much
disposable cash he has remaining so as i
said really the point i'm making is that
but by designating some of these things
at risk it does place a a fairly onerous
um obligation on the owners and i think
we need to be
slightly careful about how we treat that
mr helsin
yes um
the
addition
of properties to the risk register
doesn't impose any um
additional restrictions or expectations
on
owners it it's
to put it simply it's a list of
buildings to keep an eye on because they
are at risk of
deterioration because if they
buildings can quite easily you know
deteriorate to the state of collapse if
they're not not uh monitored
um um the
i think all the the barns on the
register are already on the register
they work on previous iterations so
we're not proposing any uh new
um uh additions
i mean on the subject of barn
conversions we've um
sometimes that re is realistically the
only um way of
enabling those sorts of buildings to
survive into the future is to find a new
use for them and we've
uh given um
bond conversions conservation design
awards uh if they're executed very very
well um the
brexit park
uh
well they have made significant progress
because of the uh enabling um
development and they have retained
um the employment of a permanent skilled
bricklayer there
who's doing
extremely uh good
good work
um but we policy our policy d3 our
heritage policy and our local plan does
commit us to maintaining an up-to-date
heritage at risk register and monitoring
historic buildings and encouraging their
their maintenance and conservation
can i just ask a supplementary on that
thank you mr house and that's that's um
very um
informative if we can just go on to the
the trestle bridge that has already been
mentioned um
and and clearly i have a non-cunery
interest as a member of essex county
councils that belongs to ethics county
council but what would be the scenario
if essex just said look this is a
long-term maintenance liability it's not
worth it
and they decide not to um not to
maintain it or indeed decide to remove
it is there any sanction over them for
if they took that course of action
the building is a
scheduled monument so it has a high
level of protection and they can't do
anything with it without permission from
historic
england um for those high more highly
graded buildings
uh
they are they tend to be eligible for
grant assistance from historic england
so it could be that they benefit from
that um i mean the local authority
does have uh powers of enforcement to
arrest deterioration um
uh though those are always a last resort
and we
try to resolve these sorts of issues
through negotiation and gentle
encouragement
um
i'm not sure i found out your question
yeah thank you very much
cancer stamp
sorry chairman i think i was napping a
bit there
i'm really pleased to see that burnham
on crouch has made it makes a nice
change we don't seem to get
notified very much or acknowledge much
at the moment
and i'm really uh mr holmes are going to
hate me but the chapel's on there and
you see he's not even looking at me he's
not engaging with me which is a shame um
and i'm really interested to actually
see that and all seriousness jokes aside
we know there is an issue with the roof
and i don't know if there's anything
that can be seen as a little bit of a
priority to get the roof mended because
it is in a beautiful location the gates
are absolutely stunning and i think it
could be looked at to be brought back
into use rather than it fall into more
decay now i think mr holmes will be
picking him up and picking him off of
his chair because uh
he knows that i was a supporter of maybe
letting it go to a folly but i don't
think it's in that much of disrepair and
i think we could actually do something
and now the district is growing
especially burning on crouch i don't see
why we can't have some investment over
there and look at actually replacing or
repairing the roof tiles
and then maybe having a long-term
project
and to actually put it back into some
sort of use we've been talking about
cemeteries earlier why can't we use it
people are going to continue sadly
passing away it is going to continue the
growth and it is a cemetery i think we
need to be looking after but i think the
report i'm going to join the bandwagon
mr hassan and say thank you very much
it's a lovely excellent report yet again
mr holmes do you want to
thank you chairman yes happy to do that
review again at the burnham cemetery it
has been a problem in terms of
maintenance for a number of years it
does need a purpose or an alternative
use so i think
we'll work with mr houston to look at
some options around that and that can
come back to this committee okay
that's the channel
thank you chairman i just wanted to
comment really if i may
um
very good report as usual but um
specifically about three black line
cottages
um which is in all thorn i live in all
thorn actually and it's we're in the
same road but it's some substantial wave
from where i am and actually the work
done on there i think the f the
photographs actually to show
what can be done um
if you've got people who really are
engaged and want to improve things and
do some refurbishment works i think it's
tinged with sadness i'm sure mr helsin
will correct me if i've got this
incorrect but i'm ready to understand
unfortunately since this photograph was
taken one of the gentlemen involved has
sadly i believe i i've got it right
passed away i hope
but i do believe that scandinavia is
quite sad although it must be lovely
before he did so to see
um the result of the work that's been
engaged here regarding councillor
durham's points and the points mr helsin
did answer regarding all bonds and
dilapidation and what it could lead to
endangerous presidents in nowhere am i
going to predetermine myself here but
many years ago at south east we did have
a dilapidated barn come forward which
officers wanted to refuse permission for
to turn into residents and the committee
on which i sat and i was one of them we
argued about we said actually it was the
one way of keeping that barn you know
surviving having a use
um we did give permission and i have to
say it's a wonderful residence now it
saved the bond council i think we're
going off for a tangent here right now
going to the point about what
dumb said and what mr houston then said
about the barnes mr dark councillor
durham i understand that however i think
we need to step out of the river it's
the way that you can i was just
highlighting the point thank you that
i've seen it actually happen in real
life to a planning committee
now wonderful um that bomb was saved and
he's now a wonderful resident thank you
councillor janna
uh cancer stamp okay i'm sorry i forgot
to mention bradley and c in the control
tower i'm really pleased that that's on
there now um and i'm not sure if there
is
regarding obviously what may happen in
the future but can that be safeguarded
through you chairman to mr harrison can
that be safeguarded and not be sold and
knocked down mr house and
uh uh
the um
the the bombing range observation tower
is in private ownership um but the um
the bradwell bay preservation group have
had a meeting with the owner and they
are
he seems quite amenable to
it being repaired
um
so fingers crossed but if the government
decides to build the power station i
think
that the um the bombing range
observation tower is his timber frame
structure by some people
yeah so you could okay that should be
all right then gentlemen about the
control tower
the control tower oh the control tower
yeah well that that's
like with if the power station goes
ahead
um
yeah that that face is not that's why i
added that to the at risk register yeah
um
because it faces destruction yeah
okay thank you mr houser chairman can i
just say that would be great shame
okay uh so uh thank you mr houston so uh
can we agree that virus sent members
thank you very much thank you mr houston
uh so now move on to agenda item 14
oh sorry
yeah here um for silver street as a
member of central planning it has now
been passed okay just in case anybody
doesn't know thank you thanks
councillor seancy
so gender item 14 uh caviar 19 economic
recovery and transformation cr cert
program additional restrictions grant
proposal found on pages 321
to
324
ms cable thank you for being patient
and being the last
lead specialist prosperity over to you
thank you mr chairman and good evening
and as the chairman rightly just
mentioned the additional restrictions
grant forms part of morgan district
council's kobig 19 economic recovery and
transformation program
this grant sits alongside the delivery
of the kobe 19 management covert 19
outbreak management and welcome back
funds
within the report details how
the remaining funds could be defrayed
through business support programmes but
it is important to note that this report
and the presentation was written prior
to the announcement on the 21st of
december from the chancellor regarding
the specific sector support for the
hospitality and leisure industry and a
third topic for the additional
restrictions grant
mr chairman i'll just share a brief
presentation with you yeah that's fine
go ahead
thank you
one moment
thank you
so the business support programs that
are
being proposed are a social enterprise
seed and sector growth fund which would
look at the
economic sustainability and growth of
social enterprises
essentially those which support
the community and community benefits and
we'd look to work with a project partner
to deliver this program so they can
so they can ascertain longevity to their
organisation and in turn support
economic growth and recovery within the
district and second bridge to that
program would be a fund targeting all
sectors which would support recovery and
future resilient resilience and again
contribute to the economic copy of the
wider district
an extension to the current uh keep it
local
program which is funded by wagnocks
which would support businesses through
one-to-one bespoke training advice and
also provide a 12-month promotional
program for them
two business support surgeries they're
being tabled one for in morden and one
for burnham on crouch and this event
would provide information and many
consultations with our trusted business
experts and partners as well as
networking opportunities with
like-minded business owners it'd be a
real opportunity for officers to to be
able to speak directly to businesses
which we have increased recently
we know the pandemic has had a
detrimental effect on people's
well-being and mental health so we're
looking at a support programme of
well-being resilience within business so
employers can spot early the signs of
negative mental health impacts and work
with their employees to mitigate these
to reduce the number of sick days and
also create a stronger more resilient
workforce
a localised membership to the federation
of small businesses we'd be looking to
look for those micro businesses that's
naught to five employees with a year's
free membership to the federation small
businesses to provide them with further
networking opportunities and support
from like-minded people and for sme
businesses which is would be five to 249
would look to subsidise that
and not provide a completely free
membership
access to grant finder we've been using
grant finder to support community
businesses and other teams in the local
authority to identify some of those
unknown grant funding opportunities the
central government ones are often well
known but there are some smaller more
localized funding opportunities that
people may not be aware with aware of
and we can promote those by our
communication channels to the local
business community
and business navigation services this
would we would look to enhance the
offering that is currently being taken
up through the north essex economic
board for businesses to be able to
easily identify relevant programs
initiative or other funding screens
other funding screens
currently on offer to support them to
access that and that would also bolster
our business engagement efforts
a visit essex membership would be a
sector-specific program for the tourism
businesses whereby they'll be able to
access
national local and regional campaigns
through visit essex whereby if they're
not a member unfortunately that they
can't participate participate in those
specific campaigns they'd also be able
to speak to sector specific um advice
and guidance and take part in excellent
training opportunities that are
available through visit essex
the sensory guide to modern district
would be the first of its kind in
england we understand and it would
support sensory awareness training for
businesses and produce a subsequent
guide this would assist businesses to
understand the sensory loss and
impairment issues that services and that
their services can be tailored to meet
customers needs as already has been
highlighted tonight not all disabilities
are visible
and we'd also be looking to
commission some additional place
photography which would support the
local development plan employment sites
and assist to promote businesses and
develop the investment prospectus
i'll stop sharing my screen now
thank you ms cable so
i would just like to say before i move
on
how
valuable i think your contribution is to
modern district council
and the amount of work that you've done
in the short period of time that you've
been here has been fantastic
and again your reports are always
extremely good and well put together so
thank you very much
so the recommendations are set out on
the report are little one that members
approved the defail approach for the
remaining additional resources
restrictions grant funding sorry and
endorse the business support schemes set
out in section 3.6 below that the
director of service today be given
delegated authority in consultation with
the chairman of strategy resources
committee to approve schemes for the
remaining additional restriction grants
to ensure defraud can be targeted to
changing business needs and restrictions
do i have a second
councillor swain
uh
councillor durham
yeah when that is required i need to uh
declare a non-canary interest
because miss cable has rent mentioned
visit ethics and i'm chairman of visit
essex
and uh again yes thank you very much hi
leander welcome to malden and uh leander
was actually a board member of visit
essex when she was a
uh an officer at braintree and was uh
he's sorely missed on the board of visit
essex but yes an excellent report thank
you very much
okay thank you counselor channel
thank you
thank you sherman i agree with the
recommendations um
and i appreciate the work that has been
done and leandra i've had conversations
with janda since she's been here and
found that enlightening
um what i would be interested in there's
any way bearing in mind how the grants
be appropriated because i'd be
interested to know regarding my ward
um if there's any businesses that do
benefit from that in my world is no way
that could be um you know when members
could be informed of how the grant's
been appropriated and to see if the
businesses in our wards have benefited
i'd be quite interested to know
i i i think that might be useful however
i think that might take up too much time
miss cable's time and i'd rather be
focused on delivering the grants
personally but
miss cable do you think that would be
something you could do i mean i'm just
assuming there could be a lot of this
where can we get the money miss cable
answer the question
i'd like to assure all members that the
access to the programs and any grant
funding is available for the entire
district
and in terms of um
understanding that data i'd need to
speak to colleagues to see if this work
could be done i have i have been asked
in my previous role um would this be
possible and
it is quite a lengthy process
and we have to be conscious of obviously
of
gdpr as well particularly if it's a
particularly small ward uh the
businesses could be identifiable or
particular persons may be identifiable
okay
thanks cable any other questions
no okay
uh so can we agree that virus sent
members
okay thank you very much cable
thank you
uh so you know moved on to a gender item
15 even uh any artisan's business that
the chairman of the committee decides
are urgent and there are none uh
therefore i draw this meeting to a close
at 21 18.
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised to please meeting probably
using the door behind me thank you very
much